واياكم على شاشه العربيه تبعناها ايضا قبل
قليل من منطقه تقسيم في اسطنبول يتحدث
الاعلام التركي عن 11
مصابا حتى هذه اللحظه يتحدث ايضا كذلك
عالم انفجار كبير انفجار ضخم في هذه
المنطقه همم
تقسيم وكما نشاهد ايضا همم اخلاء الشرطه
لهذه المنطقه تحسبا لانفجار اخر اذا
الشرطه التركيه تقلي منطقه تقسيم باسطنبول
تحسبا لانفجار همم اخر همم شاهدنا قبل
قليل الصور ايضا معكم المتداوله من هذه
المنطقه التقسيمه التي اكدها اا اكت-
وسائل الاعلام ايضا تركيا قبل قليل ايضا
هذا تاكيد من الشرطه التركيه باخلائها
لهذه المنطقه تحسبا من همم او تحسبها
لانفجارا همم اخر همم صنع بدوي انفجار
كبير في هذه المنطقه حسب ما ينقل الاعلام
التركي انفجار ضخم كبير لم يؤكد حتى دي
اللحظه كانت عمليه ارهابيه او انتحاريه قد
تمت في هذه المنطقه لكن الان الاعلام
التركيه يتحدث عن اغلاق هذه المنطقه
التقسيم في اسطنبول بعد هذا الانفجار الذي
حدث
وهمم تحدثت بانها او اتحدث هذه الصحف بانه
سمع ذوي انفجار ضخم في هذه ال- همم
المنطقه همم